hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester 11 Aaron and
Magnus Carson are battling it out for a
third place and before we check it out
do be a part of the subscribers video
2020 I will be repeating that for quite
a few videos now if you don't what it is
there will be a link in the description
below explaining everything so do check
it out and you know be a part of it you
will you know yeah enjoy it
and also we do have a nice photo again
courtesy of Leonard Otis official
photographer of the Grantchester here is
a photo of the two gentlemen both are in
good spirits as you can see and there
are the two gentlemen behind them who
made the first moves on the board d4 and
the knight to f6 so unlike children I'm
sure they they knew which moves
Magnussen Levin will play as they left
those moves on the board and if you know
who the two gentlemen are that made the
Moose comment in the in the comment
section below so we can all learn
something that being said let's check
out the game so Magnus with the white
pieces opens with d4 as you've seen in
the photo of Knight to f6 by 11 we have
9 253 d5 and Bishop to that for Magnus
goes for his London system we have c5 by
11 and now comes a III which is you know
convenient as it is the London chest
classic we have Knight to c6 and Knight
bTW - and now C captures on d4 with each
capture son d4 and Queen to b6 now
putting pressure on the d4 pawn but also
the b2 pawn so nice the b3 taking care
of both threats and now Bishop to g4 and
here Magnus just goes a 4 since okay you
it kind of looks like you can grab this
guy and then win a pawn here but you
know
Magnus wouldn't play it if this was
possible because after captures and
Queen captures Knight captures on d4
after captures and captures you get in a
lot of trouble after Bishop to b5 now
you'll lose castling privileges or even
worse if you block with the knight and
rugby 1 is just deadly you move the
Queen then you lose this guy who's this
guy and the black falls apart you can't
even trade Queens with the check because
after captures captures
you're still gonna lose the night on d7
so after a 4
just continues with a six which is a new
move in the game that there is one game
where a sex was played but a six is a
new move making room for the Queen on e7
on a7 and it is as a move eight that we
have a completely new game so calls and
pushes the Queen all the way back with
Queen a seven and now c3 a very solid
setup for white gets another defender to
the d4 pawn with East six eleven
prepares to develop the dice dark square
Bishop and Castle Bishop to e2 Magnus
also prepares the castle and now Knight
to h5 going after the dark square Bishop
with Bishop to e3 and now since the
Queen is pretty much useless on a7 first
Queen to b8 gaining control of the f4
square so maybe you can bring the knight
over to f4 would be nice as it will come
with an attack on the bishop and the G
to pawn but Magnus takes care of it with
h3 so now we have virtual characters n
f3 Bishop captures now Knight f4 isn't
really all that impressive since the
bishop is no longer any - white can just
castle so 11 just brings it back to f6
with Bishop back the e - now now Magnus
wants to bring the bishop over to d3 to
be used for attacking purposes with
Bishop to d6 now and Bishop to d3 we
have castles and Magnus castles not with
the Queen obviously so there's a mic
here so I can see the Queen and the end
the King King - g1 sorry a castling so
the King goes to G 1 and the D H 3 is
already played so you don't have to
worry about Bishop captures pawn we have
Queen to c7 now again connecting rooks
you want to get the rook into the game
rook to e1 and now comes King to h8 so
any captures on h7 will not come with
the check in the future and if you move
the knight you really know the Queen
wants to come over to h5 so we have
Queen to f3 rook 8 e8 now preparing e5
but it will be difficult to execute
b5 since the Queen is already attacking
the d5 pawn once you push e 5 you just
lose the d5 point with Bishop to g5 by
Magnus threatening just to capture the
night here
so Knight the g8 that's why King to h8
was a very nice move making room for the
night
we have looked at itto
preparing to either bring the other look
over to e1 but it will also serve as a
defender of the second rank and now
again you still can push ePHI because d5
is hanging so Knight to e7
now you could push 'if I've since the
night guards the d5 square but Magnus
goes Queen to h5 now forces Levin to
weaken either weaken the King side or
bring the knight back to g6 which Levin
does now now there is no meat on h7 and
Bishop back the c2 adding a defender to
the night if it ever gets under attack
for example if black pushes b6 captures
this maybe bring the row cover to b8 you
could have a lot of pressure on the B
file so King back to g8 you know if
Bishop captures night you want to be
able to capture with with the night here
but what you really want is to get the
rooks out of there and get the night
over to f8 so the knight can defeat
defend the h7 point from f8 with Bishop
back to d2 by Magnus and now Knight the
b4 hoping to well to either trade or
pick up the bishop Russia back to be one
and now 11 just retreats knight back to
c6
we have brushed back to d3 now by Magnus
and now of course this will not be
possible since you will not be winning
anything with the Queen and rook to b8
now Levin procures the breakthrough on
the King side so 11 is not content with
just repeating moves he he also wants to
play something Bishop to e3 by Magnus
and now he here Magnus is planning to
bring the knight over to c5 we look
after eh now clearing the f8 square for
the knight so you can defend the h7 bone
from there we have g3 and now completely
taking away the f4 square from blacks
pieces and the now Knights to f8 we have
better back to c2 now again asking 11
what do you want to play here here nice
the b4 if you play it it doesn't really
work because the rook now guards at the
bishop here so we have b6 opening up the
B file and now comes a captures on b6 we
have rook captures and b6 and now Bishop
the c1 sorry not be one Bishop to c1
now you want to move the night but you
need to defend the B to point from the
rook rook eat the b8 Levin doubles up on
the B file and now tonight the c5 as
planned as the b2 point is now nicely
protected so here Magnus is threatening
to pick up the a7 pollen but Levin
sacrifices it he says this is the
perfect opportunity to push e5 so this
is exactly what he does now characters
is met with just captures night but
Magnus picks up the a6 pawn 11 plays
Queen to a7 now the night is kind of
trapped you can't really move it because
you lose the rook on a1 but Magnus plays
the characters on e5 now attacks the
bishop here and here if you just move
the bishop then Bishop d3 and you defend
your night so it's not a problem so here
first 11 pushes the Queen back and now
he wants to move the knight Knight
captures an e5 but he wants to do it
with an attack on the Queen Queen to g4
and now Knight captures on e5 comes with
an attack on the Queen we have Queen
today for now Magnus brings a defender
to the knight and rook the c8 so what do
you what do you do here we have Bishop
to e3 now putting pressure on the rook
and the Queen and 11 blocks at with d 4
d 4 is an excellent defensive resource
because either you capture with this guy
and then you get night of free checking
each one and queen b7 threatening a lot
of nasty discoveries here or you get
Bishop captures on d4 which was played
in the game but now the bishop is on a
well not a very convenient square
because now Knight of 3 picks it up so
you get rid of this annoying threat King
G to Knight captures d4 and now Queen
captures on d4 again eliminating the
threat of rook captures here because if
rook captures an a6 now we just pick up
the Queen and after all is said and done
a white is up the exchange but also up 2
points so Magnus will be completely
winning here so after Queen d4 we have
Knight the e6 now attacking across since
Queen and here Carlson doesn't just move
the Queen and allow xi to create some
sort of an attacking setup with getting
Bishop over to c5 he just eliminated the
night rook captures F captures and
Bishop the e4
you could also start through with rook
to a2 but Magnus wants to get the rook
over to 18 now which will allow the
knight to move night before will come
with an attack on the Queen but also
once you push the beep on you want the
rook to defend the f2 on because the F
do pawn is a real weakness in cross
since position and if Levin is able to
consolidate with rook their fate may be
getting the Bishop to c5 it will be a
lot of pressure so this is how cross and
dies at first
11 goes rook to f8 you do want your rook
they're putting pressure on the f2 point
but now rooked a 2 now night to b4 is
definitely a possibility and here 11 has
two good options but he's already
starting to get very low on time one of
them is rook b7 just all for a trade of
Queens here and here you would get after
well rook to be 7 was played but rook
the f7 was also a possibility then you
get Knights the B for opening up an
attack here
but then rook captures on before rook
after Sunday 7 rook captures and d4 rook
the eight check and now not bishop not
came to discern but Bishop f8 blocking
and the now seek a person before you get
this position okay it's a it's an
endgame of bishops of opposite color but
Carson is still up to pawn so this is
one way to go about it 11 chooses the
other way he goes rook the b7 offers the
Queen trade this way and okay a
concentrate we have rook Queen captures
rook captures and now b4 and this is
what he wanted to achieve now everything
is nicely protected and you also take
away the c5 square from the bishop so
rook to b8 here 11 wants to get rook to
be 6 and start attacking the knight and
also it seems like you cannot start
pushing your C pawn but you actually can
that's why I roped the c8 was a better
idea preventing c4 but he won't work to
beat and now cross and just starts
pushing the pawn and now you cannot
capture here because of course if you
capture just Knight character so it's
not a problem
rook captures you can pick it up with
the night and you end up this in the
same game night and Bishop against the
rook which of course is winning for
white
so after c4 11 goes rook to be 6 foot
well pressure tonight but now b5 and the
knight is defended
we have King to f7 in the now rook to c2
starting to push c5 and now xi can't
just wait and see what happens even
though he's up the exchange the two
connected pass points are too strong so
he gives up one of the ropes to rugby
cactus and a6 captures captures and now
we're in the bishops of opposite color
endgame there is one rook pair on the
board as well but Magnus has a passed
pawn and of course he pushes it c5 we
have Bishop to e5 and now c6 so rook to
e7 now Magnus has to figure out how to
get to the pawn past the c7 square it's
a dark square so you're light square
Bishop is useless in helping out with
that so as long as the rook and Bishop
cover the c7 dark square you are not
getting this pawn you know over that
square so you have to introduce a second
weakness was something we often
mentioned the principle of two
weaknesses we have h4 now h5 will create
more weaknesses on the Kings side with
King to f6 and now rook to d2 we have
Bishop the c3 rook the d3 attacking the
bishop Bishop to b4 and now King to h3
with the shabak the e7 end and out f3 so
slowly but surely improving the position
with E 5 by 11 and now rook back to c3
now we have Bishop to b6 you can't allow
at the point to reach c7 and now look
back to see one with h6 by 11 but now
rook to d1 attacking the bishop bishop
back the e7 you cannot defend with the
King because you also have to keep an
eye on the g6 pawn so pink the g4 now we
have King to f7 and now rogue back to be
1 we have Bishop to d6
so it's not a problem if you trade rooks
because the bishop will be still be
guarding the queening square even after
the pawn is transferred over to the B
file so you are not cleaning that bone
ever so we have h5 starting to create a
second weakness in gk % h5 King captures
and now we get this position where 11
will have a lot of problems defending
both threats keeping an eye on c7 and
also keeping an eye on the h6 pawn
seven defending but now rook to d1
attacking the bishop bishop acted before
now rook to d5 there's a third weakness
which is the e5 pawn so rook to e7 and
now Bishop to f5 and it was in this
position unmoved 66 that 11 our engine
resigned the game as it is well it's a
certain death but you know he will just
slowly suffer until it's all over
because this is a a technical win and
for Magnus Carlsen that that will not be
a problem just to show you an idea so
like we said Black has to keep an eye
con stantly on the e5 point he can't let
let whiting rabbit he has to keep an eye
on the h6 point and he also needs to
keep an eye on the c7 square so those
are the three weaknesses in the position
and it will be impossible to keep an eye
on both of them so you need to play
something okay
you will play rook c7 you hope the trade
at this point for this point but white
can always go Bishop to e4 now if you
capture it you just create a discovery
and pick up the rook so the c6 point is
not free for grabs so look back the e7
now you're gonna go rook to d8 now you
hurt you you want to get Bishop here and
threaten rook the g8 check so they're
back to c5 Bishop d5 but now King h7
you're gonna go look the f8 and now as
you're threatening rook to f6 to pick up
the h6 pawn Bishop to e3 now you have to
defend that guy's well rook the f6 now
again black has to play a useful move
let's say Bishop g5 you're gonna go
Bishop the e4 check King g7 Bishop rook
to g6 check King to f8 and an out Bush
back to d5 now you're just threatening
rogue g8 mate so after rook to c7 you
will go
f4 now it's very easy to find useful
most captures captures now you cannot
capture because rook f6 will pick up the
bishop so you have to move it and now
after f5 now this point is marching
forward everything is nicely protected
next move you're gonna lose this pawn so
there is really no way no way to play
this even if you defend it you're gonna
you're gonna get f6 now all of these
squares are nicely protected rook the
rook the G it will be made so here black
will have no other options you will have
to give up the bishop and now your
down a piece and you're completely lost
so of course Levin knows this and he's
incredibly long time maybe even lost on
time I'm not sure but well regardless of
what happened it's a completely winning
position for white so that's why of
course either Levin resigned or he let
the time run out but yeah great win for
Magnus and an important one he still
prolongs his undefeated streak which is
now I believe a hundred and six games
undefeated streak in classical time
format and his win in the classical time
format against Levin gets him six points
so if Levin does not retaliate in the
Classical time format it will be
somewhat difficult to get to get back
like we said it's six points for winning
the class ball four points for winning
rapid and two points for a win in the
blade section but you know the match is
still young anything can happen so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
like I said be a part of the subscribers
video 2020 find all the information in
the description below the first two
three links are the ones that are
important so do check it out the
explanation is in the in the video with
the puzzle so if you haven't seen the
puzzle to check that out as well I would
like to thank Adam Decker Matt Timmerman
for several doe elite junior Randy
raveling and Paul Gauguin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester finals checking up in your
wonderful suggestions and well after all
that discovered we are continuing with
our next big saga thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day